pas une petite info bondoux / ca
il va intégrer l'école leur carte au
trésor mattingly as loupé là franchement
on est sauvé à quel autre scoop après
deux boys et de boys kids il ya une
version nouvelle de ce qui se prépare
c'est de voice seniors b bat les débats
le travail à cette adaptation pour
septembre mais aussi l'allemagne la
belgique est peut-être la france ce
serait des candidats de plus de 65 ans
intéressant que nous avons divisé sur
vivolta où ces mots ce que demain des
races canines
ça sera dit d'accord si on se coucher
après regardez pas j'ai pas encore là
dessus c'est une honte c'est tout
simplement de la discrimination j'espère
que cette version n'ira pas au bout et
si elle va au bout je mens chêneraie aux
grilles de tf1
comex est un scandale pourquoi y aurait
un jeu voice pour les seniors bah si
mais qu'on le fait d'accord ils ont
emballé le jury et le jury ça serait
quoi bcdc dès ses débuts c'était encore
plus vieux alors c'est les adultes qui
font les cuts pourquoi ce service est
bien difficile et c'est un sujet dont
c'est bien sûr à tous hommes et femmes
est attendu à l'été dernier on a passé
sur rtl un sujet le matin sur une brune
chorale de septuagénaires qui a
tellement plu que universal viennent
leur signer un contrat ça s'appelle le
groupe santa ne paient pas ils vont
sortir un album ça c'est parce que
universal a craqué donc pourquoi il n'y
aurait pas un coup de fouet en un
domaine assez risqué pardon mais c'est
risqué parce qu'en plus comme souvent
les enregistrements sont très longs et
c'est différent quelques mois après je
vois la moitié donc voilà
on passe à autre chose la vanne je suis
pas d'accord l'agent fait on maltraite
nos vieux cd pestis la pastorale abolis
au nul par horizon du pouvoir d'achat et
du temps libre et donc c'est une aubaine
au contraire pour les annonceurs et d'un
point de vue totalement cynique moi je
trouve que c'est une très bonne chose
voilà oui elle a parfaitement raison
alors on va passer les ont parfaitement
raison les bogies pas honnêtement c'est
la copine à ma soeur